wir fordern als Gewerkschaft der Polizei
flexible Grenzkontrollen auch an der
Grenzlinie aber so dass wir
unberechenbar sind nämlich niemand weiß
wann wir wo unsere Kontrollen machen
wenn wir statische
kontrollkontrollstellen haben
24 Stunden rund um die Uhr dann sind wir
berechenbar und dann muss man nicht
unbedingt über den Übergang fahren
sondern kann vielleicht auch nebenher
laufen die deutsch-polnische Grenze ist
natürlich auch mit einem Fluss gesegnet
mit dem mit der Neiße oder der oder und
die nicer derzeit teilweise nur 20 cm
das heißt oben auf der Brücke steht die
Bundespolizei und unten laufen die
Schleuser mit ihren Migranten rüber die
Innenministerin selbst ist ja auch nicht
hundertprozentig überzeugt von der
Maßnahme hat ja heute gesagt man muss
dann auch mal selber schauen was das
bringt warum lässt sie diese Kontrollen
dann vorbereiten
ja also ich habe zum Schluss gehört dass
sie auch nur flexible Kontrollen haben
möchte es ist immer die Frage der
Begrifflichkeit wie gesagt stationär
stationäre und statische Kontrollen sind
aus unserer Sicht nicht richtig
jetzt muss man gucken der Druck ist sehr
hoch nicht nur bei der
bundesinnenministerin sondern alle
Länder bei uns in Deutschland unsere
Bundesländer haben natürlich hohen Druck
und jetzt ist die Frage wie die Politik
sich generell aufstellt für uns ist aber
wichtig dass wir nicht nur die Migranten
aus diesen Autos befreien und dann
zuleiten können der Ausländerbehörde
sondern für uns ist ja auch wichtig dass
wir den Schleusern habhaft werden und da
ist es enorm wichtig nicht nur den
Fahrer sozusagen oder den Schlepper den
letzten zu bekommen sondern wir wollen
ja die Schleuser Netzwerke so wie es
eben in ihrem Bericht auch heute aus
einem Flughafen gefahren geworden ist
gehen wir noch mal gedanklich an die
Grenze da ist ja auch immer von
schleierfahndungen die Rede wo sind da
die Grenzen dieses Mittels
wir dürfen in Deutschland nach dem
bundespolizeigesetz innerhalb von 30
Kilometern von der grenzkontrolllinie
Weg unsere sogenannte Schleierfahndung
machen das ist das Mittel was uns der
schengender grenzkodex derzeit hergibt
und von daher dürfen wir innerhalb
dieses 30 Kilometer Kurve doors unsere
Aufgaben erledigen mehr als Gewerkschaft
der Polizei erforderten schon lange eine
Änderung der Gesetzesvorhaben nämlich
auch 50 km auch das ist ja leider noch
nicht passiert und das
bundespolizeigesetz ist ja leider auch
noch nicht verabschiedet worden da
springt
er muss Bundesministerium der Justiz mit
Rum und auch da muss man gucken wenn wir
wirklich effektiv arbeiten sollen muss
man uns das Handwerkszeug geben jetzt
schreibt auf Youtube Grenzschutz wie USA
Kanada Australien das ist so einfach was
sind da noch mal die Besonderheiten die
besonderen Gegebenheiten im deutschen
Recht im EU Recht
wir sind Europa wir sind nicht an der
ich sag mal USA mexikanischen Grenze wir
können hier kein Grenzzaun errichten und
das wollen wir auch gar nicht Europa ist
eine Errungenschaften wo ich sage ich
persönlich auch sage ich möchte ganz
gerne auch in meine Nachbarstaaten
reisen ohne kontrolliert zu werden das
ist eine Errungenschaft in Europa die
finde ich enorm und die darf man auch
nicht zerstören und der Druck der
Migranten ist so hoch gerade allerdings
können wir das auch nicht mit solchen
ich sag mal Mitteln wie sie jetzt da
gerade dargestellt worden sind
wir können sie nicht begrenzen das
einzige was man machen kann aus unserer
Sicht aus Sicht der Gewerkschaft der
Polizei dass man Zentren baut an den
Außengrenzen da müsste die EU anfangen
und vielleicht auch mit dem
flüchtlingswerk der UN dem UNHCR äh
prüfen welche Möglichkeiten an unseren
Außengrenzen bestehen dort Zentren zu
schaffen um eben dann eine legale
Einreise nach Europa
dazu schreibt jetzt René auf Facebook
solange die Herkunftsländer nicht
mitspielen können wir und damit meint er
die EU nur reagieren und nicht agieren
was sagen sie dazu
da hat er nicht ganz Unrecht aber
deswegen habe ich ja gerade auch gesagt
wir müssen an den Außengrenzen stehen
und dann ist es eigentlich auch völlig
egal was für ein Herkunftsland wenn wir
Ihnen erst dann reinlassen oder die
Menschen reinlassen wenn sie wirklich
das Recht haben reinzukommen dann haben
wir auch die Möglichkeit zu sagen es
legal in Europa und dann ist egal ob er
aus welchen Herkunftsland er auch kommt
wir haben vorher dann unsere Grenze die
den Schutz unserer Außengrenze und ich
glaube da ist der Ansatz genau richtig
derzeit jetzt gehen wir noch mal an die
deutschen Grenzen führen wir uns mal die
Situation vor Augen ihre Kolleginnen
ihre Kollegen treffen eben an der Grenze
auf Migranten was passiert dann genau
es wird gefragt wo sie herkommen wenn
die Sprachbarriere da ist wird es mit
Händen und Füßen gemacht in der Regel
geht man auch sofort erkennen oder auch
man gibt sich zu erkennen wo sie
herkommen und was sie wollen in der
Regel 90 bis 95% an der polnischen
Grenze sagen sie möchten ein Schutz
suchen stellen also ein Asylantrag
stellen und dann werden sie mitgenommen
zur Dienststelle sie werden dort
bearbeitet sie werden überprüft das
heißt Polizei fachlich überprüft und
wenn dann wir mit unseren Abarbeitung
fertig sind werden sie auch freien Fuß
gelassen und werden dann zur
Aufnahmestelle in Brandenburg ist die
Zentrale Aufnahmestelle in
Eisenhüttenstadt gebracht und dort
werden sie weiter bearbeitet dass
Asylverfahren macht das Bundesamt für
Migration und Flüchtlinge da sind wir
als Bundespolizei da raus das heißt um
das noch mal ganz klar zu stellen mit
dieser Maßnahme mit dieser stationären
Grenzkontrolle die jetzt gerade
diskutiert wird da wird nur eben die
Illegalität etwas reduziert es reduziert
sich aber dadurch nicht die Anzahl der
Flüchtlinge die an die Grenze kommen und
über die Grenze kommen
nein die Anzahl wird sich definitiv
nicht reduzieren wir werden höchstens
vor Ort an der Grenzkontrollstelle aus
unserer Sicht wie gesagt flexibel werden
wir die Menschen aufnehmen und fragen wo
kommen sie her was machen Sie hier wo
wollen sie hin und wenn man dann sagt
wir haben einen Schutz ersuchen also
Asyl dann müssen wir sie auch dort
aufnehmen genau das gleiche was jetzt
auch im Inland passiert bei der Schleier
fahren so jetzt sagt ihr Kollege teckart
von der Deutschen Polizeigewerkschaft
sie sind von der Gewerkschaft der
Polizei zwei unterschiedliche der findet
den Vorstoß von Nancy fazer eigentlich
gut der sagt sogar das kommt zu spät
also wie geht das dass die eine Polizei
Gewerkschaft sagt finden wir gut und die
andere nicht so
ähm wir sagen wir möchten keine
stationären statischen Grenzkontrollen
war immer der Meinung zu sagen wir
brauchen stationäre Grenzkontrollen wir
sagen wir sind für die Kollegen und
Kollegen da diese laufen derzeit
wirklich am Limit egal ob wir sie jetzt
mit flexiblen Grenzkontrollen oder in
der Steuererklärung
wir haben sehr viel Personal hier was
wirklich am Limit läuft und jetzt auch
noch stationäre Grenzkontrollen dazu
muss man sich überlegen wenn ich die
stationär mache dann habe ich 24 Stunden
rund um die Uhr dort ein Trupp stehen
mit bestimmt fünf bis zehn Leuten in
einer Schicht bei fünf Schichten in
einem 5 Schichtsystem muss man überlegen
das sind 50 Leute die für eine
Kontrollstelle brauchen wir sagen das
Personal ist nicht da um das zu machen
und deswegen sagen wir flexibel da
könnten wir gerade noch so mitgehen dass
das auch personell zu stemmen ist
allerdings kriegen wir das auch nicht
auf Dauer hin ich weiß nicht und die
Gewerkschaft der Polizei sich derzeit
auch nicht sicher wo wir das Personal in
hernehmen sollen wir sehen ja auch dass
das die Landespolizei ja auch mit der
Kräften vor Ort ist in einer sogenannten
Schleierfahndung die bundesrepolizei
derzeit unterstützt und selbst bei der
Landespolizei Sachsen ist oder ein
Brandenburg haben wir im Moment sehr
starke Bedenken dass wir das mit dem
Personal was derzeit da ist überhaupt
schaffen können auf Dauer das heißt also
wir brauchen europäische Lösung und wir
brauchen auch um Schleuser Netzwerke zu
verschlagen effektives Arbeiten und dazu
brauchen wir Personal nämlich
Spitzenpersonal Fachpersonal da hat die
Polizei die Bundespolizei zumindest in
den letzten Jahren nicht unbedingt ihre
Hausaufgaben gemacht da hoffen wir aber
dass wir dort sind wir im Gesprächen
dass das in der nächsten Zeit besser
wird jetzt fragt sich pyrofreak was
diese stationären Kontrollen an der
polnischen Grenze bringen sollen er
meint dass dadurch doch im Grunde
genommen die Arbeit der Schleuser sogar
noch erleichtert wird wem wenn diese
Kontrollen wenn Personal eben an diese
fixen Punkte gebündelt wird
das ist das was
ich in wahr bleiben
und flexiblen Möglichkeiten an den
grenzkontrollpunkten unsere Kontrollen
durchzuführen dann sind wir
unberechenbar und dann habt ihr auch
mehr Möglichkeiten den Schleuser zu
sagen hallo hier Stopp denn er wusste ja
nicht dass wir da jetzt quasi in der
nächsten zehn Minuten auftauchen in
unsere Kontrolle machen vielleicht noch
ein letzter kommentar von David wir
hatten acht Jahre Zeit und es ist nichts
passiert Zentren an den Außengrenzen zu
bauen und zu bauen wird Jahre dauern er
schreibt wir brauchen jetzt schnelle und
wirksame Maßnahmen wie könnten die
aussehen
das
ist eine gute Frage die ich nicht
beantworten kann denn wir sind für die
Kollegen und Kollegen da ich hätte jetzt
keine sofortige Lösung denn wir können
nicht anders außer nach rechts und
Gesetz arbeiten die Bundespolizei muss
jedem der ein Schutz dazu bestellen
reinlassen und weiterleiten an das
Bundesamt für Migration und Flüchtlinge
der deutsche Rechtsstaat ist so
aufgebaut dass nur das BAM und das an
für Migrationen Flüchtlinge diese
Maßnahmen überprüfen kann und auch die
Entscheidung treffen kann die
Bundespolizei selber ist bei dieser
Geschichte raus wir dürfen diese
Entscheidung gar nicht treffen
Herr Wendland ich danke Ihnen sehr für
ihre Einschätzung und dass sie uns die
Situation an den Grenzen noch mal
geschildert haben vielen Dank tschüss